now we're going to talk about five
electrolytes there are others
like phosphorus and bicarbonates
those tend to buffer the ph if things
are too acid or to alkaline
but i'm going to focus on these five
right here let's start with sodium
sodium is a mineral that helps hydrate
things because it's water is attracted
to it and of course if you have too much
sodium you're going to retain
fluid but if you don't have enough
sodium you're not going to hydrate the
cells
as well also sodium is involved in
oxygen
transport so if you're getting uh
swelling in the
red blood cells for example you're not
going to be able to carry
oxygen to the body and you're going to
actually kind of run out of air so
you could have all sorts of problems
with endurance for example if you're low
in sodium
let's say you uh you do this huge
workout and you're sweating and you lose
your sodium
you're going to be very very tired and
you're not going to be able to like walk
up the stairs because you're going to
run out of oxygen
sodium also works with chloride
as in salt for various things but sodium
also works with
other minerals like potassium there's a
pump called the sodium potassium
pump and the purpose of that pump is to
generate
electrical potential and you can look at
that as like a battery it's basically
these two are necessary
in making sure that there's enough
electrical charge inside that cell
because your cells are mini batteries
they have voltage
and the reason why your body is designed
like that is to
power the nerve and
muscle interaction the contraction of
the muscle
and the firing of the nerves okay so
if you don't have enough sodium or
potassium that pump can't work
and you're not going to be able to
activate the nerve impulses
or the muscles to work so there's a lot
of
problems that can happen with potassium
deficiency and
sodium deficiency and you're going to
feel tired and weak
on both of these right here now when we
get to magnesium
magnesium controls the absorption of
sodium and potassium so this is a very
important
mineral as well the most of the
population is deficient in magnesium
magnesium is at the core of chlorophyll
which is in all the leafy greens
an average person consumes probably a
cup and a half of
vegetable per day and they're usually
deficient in magnesium
magnesium also is associated with oxygen
like sodium
but it's mainly about relaxation of the
muscle
whereas calcium is about the muscle
contraction
so these work together to contract and
relax the muscle
so magnesium is there to also prevent
cramping
so when you're deficient in magnesium
you get muscle cramps
but if you're deficient in calcium you
can also get
muscle cramps magnesium is real
necessary
in your workouts especially if you do
long workouts
or intense workouts let's say you're
doing a bench press where you're doing
some type of
intense pushing motion or something that
you have to have
some sustained contraction then you need
a lot of magnesium
and so if you find that you can't work
out very long or very intensely
you may need magnesium or you may need
calcium i notice when people are
deficient in calcium
they lose their grip strength they just
cannot lift as much weight
but calcium is also about neuromuscular
excitability
so it's the nerve stimulus of the muscle
just like potassium right if there is a
calcium deficiency
what can happen is you can get too much
of this
and get tetany where you have this
little twitching going on
either in the left eye your arm or
throughout the body now this can also
happen in the heart
too so heart palpitations really are a
problem with
electrolytes when you're low on calcium
you get a muscle cramp
and you'll also have skeletal muscle
weakness
and then chloride works with sodium and
it has everything to do with
hydration now there's a lot of other
functions of these minerals
that relate to other things that aren't
associated with
the electrolytes so i just wanted to
focus in on these electrolytes for this
video hey before you go real quick
i have a course entitled how to
bulletproof
your immune system it's a free course i
want you to take it
and here's why here's you
here is your environment
everyone is focused on this over here
avoiding
your environment but what about here
what about strengthening
your immune system that's what's missing
this course
will show you how to bulletproof
yourself and so you can tolerate and
resist
your environment much better by
strengthening
your own immune system i put a link down
in the description right down below
check it out and get signed up today